character you're portraying not a
character a real human being but he
spends a lot of time he's a Red Sox fan
he goes to Red Sox games and so as part
of making this movie you've gotten to go
to a lot of Red Sox game II be part of
that culture but you're really not that
interested in professional sport that's
not fair I'm really interested I'm just
not knowledgeable okay like meaning like
when I pick up the bat you don't know
what was that sport yeah I know like I
you know like I just I just was not
where I was right like my dad my dad we
played sports I play sports I am
actually at like but like he never
really like we never knew all the
details he was always like let's go to
the theater you know so I like I know
like who was treated from like the
Lyceum theater on Broadway to court
Peter and 70 yeah you know where the
really good seat is in the orchestra
like I know when Meryl Streep killed it
at the public right like we didn't
really do me a lot of service in high
school right uh you know it's it's
working okay for me now yeah it's
working great for you yeah you can get
in shape for any role obviously yeah
yeah yeah sure yeah yeah what was that
quick I don't know I was weird trying to
help you out oh yeah you know I can
definitely get in shape for roles
yeah
[Applause]
you